Komputasi yang bertanggung jawab dipahami
sebagai pengembangan quantum computing
dengan kesadaran akan kekuatannya
dan potensi dampaknya. Ketika kita bicara soal tanggung jawab,
kita perlu mengembangkan dan menggunakan teknologi
berdasarkan prinsip-prinsip yang telah ditetapkan untuk membantu kita mencegah
dan meminimalkan potensi kerugian,
sambil mendorong solusi yang secara proaktif
inklusif dan akuntabel. Di IBM,
kami sudah didorong oleh rasa tanggung jawab
kepada masyarakat selama beberapa dekade. Hari ini kami menyebut diri kami sebagai katalis
yang membuat dunia bekerja lebih baik. Artinya kami
punya tanggung jawab untuk mempertimbangkan implikasi dari
teknologi yang kami bangun dan bantu terapkan.
Saat kami mengembangkan teknologi baru ini,
keputusan yang kami buat hari ini akan mempengaruhi masa depan,
dan keputusan-keputusan ini
berpotensi memberi dampak besar bagi masyarakat.
Misalnya, kamu mungkin harus memutuskan apakah akan mengejar aplikasi
yang hanya menguntungkan segelintir pemangku kepentingan, atau
yang mungkin bisa memecahkan masalah sosial.
Kami berharap kamu sebagai klien bisa berpikir
tentang pengembangan quantum computing yang bertanggung jawab.
Berpikir secara bertanggung jawab bisa membantu bisnismu membangun kepercayaan
dengan investor dan konsumen,
sekaligus membangun reputasi integritas
dan kekaguman dari karyawanmu
dan pelanggan. Di sisi lain,
ini bisa melindungimu dari pemberitaan buruk, denda,
dan sanksi. Dalam video ini,
kami akan memperkenalkan pertimbangan tanggung jawab yang penting
untuk didiskusikan bersama tim,
saat kamu menjelajahi quantum computing
dan aplikasinya. Dalam konteks quantum computing,
berpikir dan bertindak secara bertanggung jawab
berarti mengikuti serangkaian prinsip
dan nilai untuk memandu pengembangan
dan penerapan teknologimu.
Misalnya, ini berarti bersikap transparan
tentang keterbatasan maupun kemampuan
quantum computing. Saat ini kami punya klausul
dalam kontrak kami yang mengharuskan klien IBM Quantum
menggunakan sistem kami secara bertanggung jawab
dan tidak menggunakan sistem kami
untuk tujuan jahat atau ilegal.
Kami menyebut ini sebagai klausul penggunaan bertanggung jawab
dan penggunaan yang dapat diterima.
Klausul ini sudah mempengaruhi cara klien kami berpikir
tentang pengembangan quantum
untuk kasus penggunaan mereka. Kami juga bisa
ikut mempengaruhi arah quantum computing
dengan memutuskan aplikasi mana yang kami kejar
untuk pengembangan dan percepatan.
Untuk melindungi dari potensi penggunaan yang tidak bertanggung jawab
atas teknologi kami, kami juga telah mengembangkan teknologi IBM Quantum
yang andal. Saat kamu memikirkan bagaimana
dan untuk apa menggunakan quantum computing,
pastikan kamu berbicara secara realistis tentang ekspektasimu
terhadap quantum computing dan jangka waktu
kapan kamu berharap bisa mengintegrasikan quantum.
Jangan gambarkan quantum computing
sebagai sesuatu yang misterius, tapi cobalah jelaskan secara realistis
sebagai perangkat keras komputasi
yang mengikuti hukum fisika kuantum.
Pastikan kasus penggunaan quantum computing-mu
bersifat inklusif secara proaktif
dan mempertimbangkan semua pemangku kepentingan yang terlibat
untuk menentukan sejauh mana
dampak negatif terhadap masyarakat.
Pastikan kamu sudah mendefinisikan prinsip-prinsip yang jelas
dan nilai-nilai untuk eksplorasi kasus penggunaanmu
dan pengembangannya. Terima kasih
sudah menonton. Kami berharap
saat kamu membawa quantum computing yang bermanfaat ke dunia,
kamu juga akan memikirkan bagaimana melakukannya secara bertanggung jawab.
Itu tadi.